this is Jocko podcast number 370 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening so if you are
listening and you didn't listen to the
last podcast number 369 go back and
listen to it this is a continuation of
that podcast
[Music]
we are talking about the games we are
playing
subordinate games that make up various
aspects of life and then ultimately the
game of life itself
and
just to say this and we kind of talked
about this on the last one recognition
of the game is
a huge part of the battle just
recognizing that there's a game going on
is a huge part of the battle it's like
when uh people are alcoholics and sort
of the the beginning of solving the
problem is admitting oh I'm an alcoholic
that's what they say or realizing
that you've been hustled in uh in pool
right sure like like if you don't know
that you're getting hustled yeah
they're playing a game with you yeah you
you you literally stop getting hustled
as soon as you recognize what's
happening uh three card the three card
shuffle you ever seen that yeah
you think you're gonna win that game
they're playing a game they're playing a
different game than you are you're
trying to watch that card like an idiot
hey you realize someone's playing you in
a relationship right that's a common
term we don't talk about the game but we
talk about getting played getting played
yeah once you know you're getting played
hopefully you go oh okay now I
understand the game that's happening I'm
losing the game I'm gonna get out of the
game yeah
if you don't know there's a game going
on you're just going to lose the game
so that's kind of the Prime primary
piece of information from the last
podcast was to make sure you know you
are in a game
I'm going to go back to David Foster
Wallace's commencement speech which I
talked a little bit about on the last
podcast here's another excerpt
he says this by way of example
let's say it's an average adult day
then you get up in the morning go to
your challenging White Collar college
graduate job and you work hard for eight
or ten hours and at the end of the day
you're tired and somewhat stressed and
all you want to do is go home and have a
good supper and maybe unwind for an hour
and then hit the sack early because of
course you have to get up the next day
and do it all again
but then you remember there's no food at
home you haven't had time to shop this
week because of your challenging job so
now after work you have to get in your
car and drive to the supermarket it's
the end of the work day and the traffic
is apt to be very bad
so getting to the store takes way longer
than it should and when you finally get
there the supermarket is very crowded
because of course it's the time of day
when all the other people with jobs also
try and squeeze in some grocery shopping
and the store is hideously lit
and also infused with soul-killing music
or corporate pop and it's pretty much
the last place you want to be but you
can't just get in and out quickly you
have to wander all over the huge overlit
stores confusing aisles to find the
stuff you want and you have to maneuver
your junkie cart through all these other
tired hurried people with carts etc
etc cutting stuff out because of the
long ceremony here and eventually you
get
all your supper supplies except now it
turns out that there aren't enough
checkout lanes open
even though it's the end of the day rush
so the checkout line is incredibly long
which is stupid and infuriating
but you can't take your frustration out
on the lady on the Frantic lady working
the register who's overworked at a job
who's daily tedium and meaninglessness
surpasses the imagination of any of us
here at a prestigious college but anyway
you finally get to the checkout lines
front and you pay for your food and you
get told to have a nice day in a voice
that is absolutely the voice of death
then you have to take your creepy flimsy
plastic bags of groceries in your cart
with the one crazy wheel that pulls
Mattingly to the left all the way
through the crowded bumpy literary
parking lot and then you have to drive
all the way home through slow heavy SUV
intensive rush hour traffic etc etc
everyone has done this of course but it
hasn't been part of your graduates
actual life routine
day after day week after week month
after month year after year
but it will be
and many more dreary annoying seemingly
meaningless routines besides but that is
not the point the point
is that petty frustrating crap like this
is exactly where the work of choosing
is gonna come in
because the traffic jams and crowded
aisles and long checkout lines give me
time to think and if I don't make a
conscious decision about how to think
and what to pay attention to I'm gonna
be pissed and miserable every time I
have to shop because my natural default
setting is the certainty that situations
like this are really all about me
about my hungriness and my fatigue and
my desire to just get home and it's
going to seem for all the world like
everybody else is just in my way
and who are all these people in my way
and look at how repulsive most of them
are and how stupid and cow-like and
dead-eyed and non-human they seem in the
checkout line or at how annoying and
rude it is that people are talking
loudly on cell phones in the middle of
the line and look at how deeply and
personally unfair this is
or of course if I'm in a more socially
conscious liberal arts form of my
default setting I can spend in the end
of the day traffic being disgusted by
all the huge stupid Lane blocking SUVs
and Hummers and V12 pickup trucks
burning their wasteful selfish 40 gallon
tanks of gas and I can dwell on the fact
that the Patriotic or religious bumper
stickers always seem to be on the
biggest most disgustingly selfish
Vehicles driven by the ugliest this is
the an example of how not to think
most disgustingly selfish Vehicles
driven by the ugliest most inconsiderate
aggressive drivers and I can think about
how our children's children will despise
us for wasting all the Futures Fuel and
probably screwing up the climate and how
spoiled and stupid and selfish and
disgusting we all are and how modern
consumer Society just sucks
and so forth and so on you get the idea
if I choose to think this way in a store
and on the freeway fine lots of us do
except
thinking this way
tends to be so easy and automatic
that it doesn't have a choice
it is my natural default setting it's
the automatic way that I experience
boring frustrating crowded parts of
adult life when I'm operating on all the
automatic unconscious belief that I am
the center of the world and that my
immediate needs and feelings are what
should determine the world's priorities
the thing is of course
there are two there are totally
different ways to think about these kind
of situations in this traffic all these
vehicles stopped and idling in my way
it's not impossible that some of these
people in these SUVs have been in
horrible audio auto accidents in the
past and now find driving so terrifying
that their therapist has all but ordered
them to get huge heavy SUV so they can
feel safe enough to drive or that the
Hummer that just cut me off is maybe
being driven by a father whose little
child is hurt or sick in the seat next
to him and he's trying to get his kid to
a hospital and he's in a bigger more
legitimate hurry than I am
it is actually I who am in his way
or I can choose to force myself to
consider the likelihood that everyone
else in the supermarket checkout line is
just as bored and frustrated as I am and
that some of these people probably have
harder more tedious and more painful
lives than I do
again please don't think that I am
giving you moral advice or that I'm
saying you are supposed to think this
way or that anybody expects you to just
automatically do it because it's hard it
takes will and effort
and if you are like me some days you
won't be able to do it or you just flat
out won't want to
but most days
if you're aware enough to give yourself
a choice you can choose to look
differently at this fat dead-eyed over
made-up lady who just screamed at her
kid in the checkout line
maybe she's not unusually like this
maybe she's not usually like this maybe
she's been up three straight nights
holding the hand of a husband who's
dying of bone cancer or maybe this very
lady is the low wage clerk at the motor
vehicle department who just yesterday
helped your spouse resolve a horrific
infuriating red tape problem through
some small Act of bureaucratic kindness
of course none of this is likely
but it's also not impossible
it just depends on what you want to
consider
if you're automatically sure that you
know what reality is and you are
operating on your default setting then
you like me probably won't consider
possibilities that aren't annoying and
miserable
but if you really learn how to pay
attention then you will know there are
other options
it will actually be within your power to
experience a crowded hot slow consumer
hell type situation as not only
meaningful
but sacred on fire with the same force
that made the Stars love Fellowship the
mystical Oneness of all things deep down
not that that mystical stuff is
necessarily true
the only thing that's capital T true
is that you get to decide
how you're going to try to see it
so
the reason that I wanted to go back to
this
speech
is because it points out the fact
that it's very easy it's it's extremely
easy
to go through life on autopilot
right to actually go through life
seeing things through miserable colored
lenses right you know you get the rose
colored lenses it's really easy to go
through life it with just seeing
everything is miserable just like it's
that that's easy
we actually get to choose the way we
look at things sometimes we don't even
realize that we have a choice
we get numbed down and we get dumbed
down and I think that's why oftentimes
people don't realize that they're in a
game
bounce it
so
they end up just simply following along
and just existing in the game without
noticing that it's being played
now
there's a couple things to think about
as we continue this discussion about the
games and playing games and the game
that we're in
with games in any game
well in most games
there's chances there's there's a level
of luck involved
good luck bad luck right I mean it
happens on a football field to get a bad
bounce you get a good bounce that can be
win or lose the game
that in wrestling they literally toss a
coin in wrestling
who unit top position who's gonna be a
bottom position if you're a great top
player you could and you're bad at the
bottom player
you can literally win or lose the game
on on a coin toss
so there's there's a certain aspect a
certain element of luck
in any game
and there's a certain aspect of luck
in life right oh it's really nice to be
born into a good family with with health
and money and connections and stability
that's that's great right
and there's there's a certain amount of
skill that can you can be
lucky enough to have yeah you want to be
a basketball player it's really nice
when you're six nine
right
or if you want to go into academics and
you have a a photographic memory that's
you're pretty lucky and not everyone
gets that gift
you're in the business world and you
have a good knack for numbers those are
those are nice things to have
so there's luck
and there's some skill that you are
that you you might just have
through that luck
but
and this is sort of lends to what we've
talked about in the last podcast
your play
that has the most impact in dictating
success or failure
it's you it's the way it's how you play
the game that counts
now
we need to think about this
because if you were six nine probably be
a pretty good pretty good decision to
get into basketball there's no guarantee
but you you at least you're kind of got
to be on on the map a little bit I mean
in high school you're going to be a
dominant player you're six nine you're
gonna be a dominant player
so
you gotta kind of make a decision about
what
game you're gonna play
and that that starts to
play a role in whether you're going to
win or lose the game because if you're
six nine and you decide to become a
gymnast
you're going to have issues
right sure you're going to have issues
if you're five two five three
and you decide you're going to play
basketball you're probably gonna have
some issues now it can be done
right Mugsy Bogues five three
5'3 I think he's five three you know
Mugsy Bogues yeah
five three
playing the NBA which is crazy and like
playing in the end it was him sitting on
a bench yeah he's playing in the NBA
you know he didn't get he didn't get
that gift but what matters is how he
played
so
we have to pay attention to that that
you have a choice as to what game you're
gonna play
what games you're going to play you have
a choice into how you're going to keep
score you have a choice in
what means winning and what means losing
so
when it comes to life
what game are we playing what rules
and how do we win
we were talking about the broad the
Supreme Game of Life
you could probably start with uh
Maslow's hierarchy of needs right so
this guy is he this guy Maslow
um Abraham Maslow born in Brooklyn 1908
died in 1970 he's a psychologist and he
made up this motivational hierarchy in
psychology
and this was his biggest contribution
and so the the base of the pyramid the
lowest thing but the most important
thing that you have to get out of the
gate is your physiological needs
obviously air water food shelter sleep
clothing
reproduction like these are the base
needs that you have
those are your physiological needs
above that in his according to his
hierarchy is safety
so personal security like how can you
make sure that you're safe and they
include in this like employment and
resources and health and property all
those things are sort of wrapped up in
safety the next one up is love and
belonging you know I don't know I have
to say the L word on the podcast but
it's love and belonging this is
friendship this is intimacy this is
family this is a sense of connection you
got esteem is the next one
which is respect and and status and
recognition and strength and freedom and
then you get self-actualization
which is
the desire
for a human to maximize their potential
so
some of the characteristics of that are
how you perceive reality that you can
that someone that's self-actualized can
perceive reality the way it is now we've
talked about this before like everyone's
perception of reality is different
so we don't really how we judge in that
one not really 100 sure these people
itself have self-actualized actualized
they can accept themselves for what they
really are
which again
that's an interesting one because if
you are Mugsy Bogues and you're like
well I just have to deal with the fact
that I'm 5'3 and I'll never no actually
he didn't accept it
um
except other people for who they are
they're not self-centered they're
creative they're resistant to conformity
they appreciate basic life experience so
that's this that's this hierarchy of
needs
right you've got your physiological
needs your safety
I get it we got to start with that
Food Water Shelter sure we get that if
you don't have that you're there's not
much else going on
um safety sure we get that if you're
under constant fear if you're the if
you're the mouse trapped with the cat
that's not good you got to figure out
then you get to this one belonging
laughs
not everyone has this deep desire to
belong like I get it it's a pretty
common
but some people prefer to be alone I
mean there's such a thing as a hermit
right yeah and and I think different
people would prioritize this differently
I get that you could say for most people
we want to have some social belonging
but I think this varies a lot
that being said I think it's a strong I
think in most people it is a pretty
strong thing
you know that's why we have tribes
that's why we have gangs that's why we
have freaking Democrats and Republicans
that's why we have
uh sports teams that people wear the I
mean can you imagine how much it's
billions of dollars that sports teams
makes from the sales of merchandise so
you can wear your your gang's Insignia
on your jersey
so that clearly indicates you don't
spend that kind of money if you don't
want some kind of sense boring so so
this is I'm just saying not everyone
feels this way but it's definitely one
of those things that I can understand
esteem now we get a healthy a healthy
ideal like you're talking about oh I
want to be esteemed I have good
self-esteem at what point does this
start turning into ego right
my status that's what my concern is yeah
like why is that
or recognition I really want to be
recognized that's really
that's ego man
and I'm not saying it's there for sure
if you can I would recommend you break
break away from that ego anchor that's
pulling you into status and pulling you
into recognition
and then you get this idea of
self-actualization
again to me this is like an ideal you've
got someone that's like focused on
coming who they are right yeah am I
being too am I being too much am I
getting too hard
uh well yes
and it kind of was this the status ego
esteem part that's where you've begun
your journey into too hard in the paint
so the the status and ego recognition
and stuff then again I don't know I
could be wrong I don't I can't read
Maslow's mind but this is what it seems
like it's like an inner need now if you
need this above and beyond normal stuff
then it starts to mutate right like just
like how you say like a healthy there's
a healthy yeah versus an inflated ego
where the inflated ego is like bad you
start you know there's a dichotomy as
one might say so like the um like uh
we'll say recognition for example right
it's not to say that like
someone's pining and yearning very very
hard for the recognition it's just that
when you get recognition for something
you did good it's going to be hard to
find somebody who just doesn't care
doesn't make them feel good right so
there that is an indicator there is some
need in there you know not to say
they're gonna break their back or throw
their mom under the bus for that
recognition that's like mutated you know
I was gonna say not saying that they
wouldn't do that because certain people
have done that yes sir yes sir and I
would imagine this kind of goes for
everything where yeah it can kind of go
too far or whatever but generally
speaking we're talking about the normal
level of hey I want to be I want to feel
belonging I want to feel esteemed if I
want to feel uh recognized and
appreciated and you know all these
things that we normal people we like to
feel so what I'm saying is you have to
ask yourself if that's the game you're
gonna play
um
that is that the game You're Gonna Play
you want recognition Okay you want
status okay
so that's that you want this
quote-unquote
self-actualization what does that
actually mean that can mean a lot of
different things so look there's people
that like self-actualization is becoming
a Buddhist monk in Thailand right yeah
yeah there's some people
self-actualization is becoming you know
the Jujitsu Champion right there's
something going down the line yeah so
that that's a that's a real vague term
yeah
I'm sure some psychologist is gonna
chime in from the Sheep seats it's very
popular and if he does he's probably
gonna say what I'm saying where it's
like oh don't think
don't think of it in terms of like an
ego
extreme terms think of it in normal
terms you know like you want food oh
well just because centering his whole
life over pursuing food no no no no
that's not what we're saying we're just
saying you know so it's an ideal each
one of these if we view them as an ideal
they're somewhat more acceptable
but they are games and we the last
podcast we talked about these some of
these specific games we talked about
work we talked about health and fitness
we talked about relationships we talked
about life
talking about Legacy a little bit the
and those are sensible Pursuits for most
people after Water Shelter food and
safety
in my opinion
work
like good job occupation health and
fitness yes good relationships yes maybe
the relationships that that that's in
belonging right
maybe the work goes into a steam of
recognition and status
so I'm just trying to line these up and
understand what I think with what some a
little bit more you know academic
version of this is
but
when we talk about these when we talk
about esteem we talk about job and we
talk about life we talk about
recognition
you could put these into into various
games
with various reward systems with various
ways of winning and a real obvious one
is money
a lot of people they're playing the game
of trying to gather up money
um
and I think
really
money is a little bit of a
substitute for Freedom right it's
supposed to be that if you have more
money you eventually get freedom and
there's the whole idea that you know
someone is a ski bum they don't have any
money they work you know up on the
mountain they're lifty up on the
mountain and they got to work four hours
in the morning every day but they're
skiing every day yeah so they even
though they have money they're kind of
doing what and meanwhile there's another
guy that's working 80 hour weeks down in
you know down in the city yeah and he
busts his ass so he can go up and ski
for those six days vacation right
so
you're supposed to be getting freedom
from money
doesn't always work out that way
pursuit of money
can actually end up being sort of an
addiction as well where now that's what
it becomes your master
and and listen I've known people
that they love that game they literally
love making money like deals and they
love it and every time they make money
it's it's incredibly rewarding to them
if they're lucky
they're good at that game
and and I've got friends that are really
good at making a lot of money and
they're good at it and they're happy and
they you know you ever wonder well how
many millions of dollars do you need
right right people like oh more but they
they are hey they got enough money to do
whatever they want you know what they
want to do they want to get more money
because that's the game that they're
playing and they love that game yeah
and
some people
want to play that game they're not good
at it they're not good at making money
and they're not going to be happy
so
that's terrible because you get someone
that's not really good at making money
and they playing that game and they
don't win and they're not going to be
happy
so you got to be careful when it comes
to the money making game
are you good at it we talked about last
time are you in the are you playing the
game with money that's going to make you
a lot of money
because if you're working you know 80 90
100 hours a week
in the wrong game you're not making any
money
you know you make fifty two thousand
dollars a year working 80 hour a week
you're a hard worker you're smart but
it's just not getting you there
you got to be playing a different game
now
the thing the weird thing about so this
is one example right it's a common
example people are playing the game for
money because there's all kinds there's
people that make
all kinds of stuff into their game like
what they're into right and it's sort of
ecosystems right you could be into
Jujitsu you want that to be that's what
you're doing to you or a basketball
player or Academia right people pursue a
life in Academia they want to win that
game they want to get the most
prestigious College they want to get the
most prestige they want to write the
prestigious paper that gets published in
the procedures uh what they call that
journal yeah
there's people that
the game that they're playing is cars
right like getting cool cars
or being in the military I always got to
bring that one up I was in the military
I was playing that game yeah I was in
that game
you're trying to get you know get the
right job work in the right place
you know I want to be a seal
uh
people are in the chess
people into women like you name it and
there's someone that's gonna make that a
huge part of the game that they're
playing foreign
can do this with anything and actually
you know in the book final spin sure the
that's sort of the character of Artie
the cleaner who's totally into washing
machines and dryers and folding laundry
and stuff like that that's sort of a a
statement about people that are just
into random things and that's the main
game that they're playing in their life
here's what's kind of good about some of
those games
is that they're def there's they're
defined
right so you want to be a jiu jitsu
Champion okay
here's what you do here's you train you
compete if you want to get to the
Pinnacle you learn these moves you cut
weight you get to this Championship you
win that's defined what you do Academia
right same thing like oh you want to be
you want to be a respected academic go
to this school go to this school go to
this school get this degree get this
degree this degree get write your paper
for the journal right do those things
and eventually you're at the Apex or
you're at least in the top percent of
this academic group military is really
defined
oh you're gonna go in you're going to
get this job you're going to do this job
you're going to promote
so
they tell you what the game is
they tell you how to compete and they
tell you how what winning is
so in in some respects those games kind
of have something cool to them
they're defined what's bad about some of
those games
is there they're not as all-encompassing
as people think so people get wrapped
around being the best Jiu Jitsu player
the best basketball player the best
academ best in Academia the best in the
military happens a lot with the military
right we see that the person's doing the
military thing and then all of a sudden
their career is over
like hey you're a general or an admiral
in the military
let's say you're a four-star Admiral or
a three-star General
bro you are kind of a a king right
you're kind of a king you have a
chauffeur your people Vehicles driving
you around you get off the plane there's
people waiting for you they set their
whole schedule around you you've got
you've got billions of dollars at play
like with fuel for ships and planes and
oh hey I want to take this plane over
here you can do it yeah
you're you're sort of this incredibly
empowered person
and then one day you retire
and all of a sudden all that stuff is
gone now look you're probably gonna go
get a job at some military company and
fuel that military industrial complex
but even then even then you're just
another at that point you're another
Admiral you're another they got they got
28 animals they got 47 generals so you
all of a sudden you're just a person
again yeah
or you're in the SEAL Teams or you're in
force Recon or you're in marsok or
you're a green brand that's all you hey
man you walk in you're an army dude
you're an art you're a green Bahrain you
walk into a you know a conventional Army
of Italian also people are giving you
respect yeah
once you get out whatever
your Jiu Jitsu or you're a fighter UFC
fighter
you know what happens when you're done
what are you doing
you were a champion
or you were a contender
now the sudden you look around what do
you have you got people are doing better
now in the UFC but
10 years ago even five years ago I guess
ago 10 years ago
if you are the champion of the world
and then you couldn't fight anymore for
whatever reason you got too old or you
got beat up too much or you you know you
were just done you got injured
what do you have
those guys literally don't have any
money they just there's nothing
so all of a sudden you look up from one
of those games the types of games that
we're talking about you look up from
that game and all of a sudden you don't
have anything yeah
have anything you won the game
you won the game yeah
damn you know I was talking uh
with a very senior
flag officer I'm not going to narrow it
down
between the services but uh Admiral
General type with multiple stars on
their collar is that what flag officer
yeah because they have their own flag
that fly skin it's like you know you
show up you're a flag officer they fly a
flag for you one star two star
three-star flag gets flown damn okay
but he was telling me about another flag
officer that he had spoken to and
the other flag officer was even more
senior to him
and that senior flag officer retired and
the junior flag officer was like oh you
know how's retirement going you know do
you miss the Navy and he's
like I said it was the Navy but yeah it
was the Navy
he goes uh do you miss the do you miss
the Navy and he's like nah it's all
[__] and I was like damn
a very senior person not he wasn't in
the SEAL Teams but a very senior person
saying that his career we'd spent you
know what 25 30 maybe even over 30 years
that's all [__]
but when this is this is he was in the
game knew he was in the game but thought
that that was the Supreme game and it
wasn't
and when he got out he looked around and
said damn
I was playing this game over here I was
like the most dominant freaking kickball
player on the school field yeah
and I was the champion and people had to
give me their their cookies at lunch
because I beat them and then all of a
sudden he looks like gets like leaves
the school field and realize there's
Major League Baseball right or he just
wasn't it's just a little tiny game yeah
so we as people need to be cognizant of
the fact
and recognize the game that we're that
we're focused on and make sure that that
game
is
what we want it to be
make sure that it's
equivalent for the effort that we're
putting into it
and look there's some people they get
out of the army they get out of the Navy
they get out of the Marine Corps
and they're they're totally stoked
they're like oh yeah I played that game
it was awesome I loved it I'm retired
now
I'm good with it I'm glad I invested all
that time and effort into that game
because I loved it I feel that way yeah
like I don't feel I got out of the SEAL
Teams I was like damn that was freaking
awesome
that was awesome loved every second of
it
if you don't pay attention you might be
putting your time and effort into a game
that's not as important as you think it
is
so be careful of that
you can see this with social media as
well right like people think
that Social Media Matters
in a big way
and it's like oh actually you know well
actually you could go off social media
and okay sure someone might be like oh
my gosh oh what happened oh actually
they wouldn't say oh my gosh no they'd
be like oh I noticed you remember on
social media earlier I canceled my
account I left oh it's taking too much
time yeah it wouldn't be like oh my oh
my gosh is every you know people like oh
probably just aren't around yeah
there's probably only a handful of
people that would notice to be honest
with you for most of us yeah yeah for
sure be like oh whatever and and the
same thing the likes and the follows and
the comments and the subscribers and all
that stuff it's like oh whatever yeah
whatever it doesn't really matter not
that big of a deal but if you think
that's a big deal
and something happens with it that's a
problem bro that's a problem
so
when you're investing a lot into a game
make sure that it's the right game
and if this game really matters
and then figure out if you should be
actually playing this game
or not
or how long are you going to play it for
what are you going to invest in it you
can play a different game maybe you can
pursue what you truly want to pursue
and what we have to be careful of
when you start asking these questions
you can't lie to yourself
because this is where
this is where real problems begin
uh so I got I was in a few years ago
2020 because it was a Jocko live event
it was in New York
and a guy asked a question you know um
he said hey this guy's fired up
he says hey you know I got a good job
I make really good money I have a happy
family I got a wife and two kids 2.5
kids whatever it was
you know she had a good life he's
explaining
he said no I just can't find the
motivation to get up in the morning and
do more
and as I thought through this
I told him he
is very well the reason he's asking this
question is because he's lying to
himself
and he's lying to himself he's lying it
to himself in one of two ways
the first way that he could be lying to
himself is he's lying to himself
that he wants to do more that's a lie
like I I really want to get up and I
want to do more there's a chance that
that's a lie
because if it's really there when you
feel that lack of achievement when you
feel that you could do more when you
know you're not Reaching Your Potential
that eats you up you don't need to find
a motivation motivation finds you you
can't sleep because you want to do more
so
there's a chance that this guy's lying
to himself
about the fact that he wants to do more
and he's actually content the other lie
that he could tell could be telling is
that he's when he says he's happy and he
has a good job and he has great money
and he has a happy family there's a
chance that
that doesn't really exist there's a
that if all that stuff was good to go he
wouldn't really feel the need to want to
do more so he's looking at it probably
oh hey I'm totally good to go no you're
not so tell the truth about that be like
you know what I'm making good money but
I want to make more money I'll set my
kids up for life I want to take a better
care of my wife I want to be able to
spend I want to be able to get a
vacation whatever those things are tell
the truth and if you tell the truth
about those things you go you know what
if I want to get another home if I want
to get a vacation home I need to work I
need to bust my ass I need to break out
I need to get up early I need to do more
stuff
and listen there's some people
that are totally happy
and content with the rents covered the
car payments handled the Netflix account
is paid off right we're good oh yeah
that's not supposed to elicit a hell
yeah from you but there's people like
this there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with that if
that's where you're at and you're like
hey look I got a rent got a cool place I
got you know I got it I got my Netflix
covered I got
um you know got a cool car we're all
good got a nice girlfriend we're all
good
there's people that legitimately are
content with that
there's also people that say we're all
good and they're not they're lying to
themselves
so don't lie to yourself
and in this case
that I was talking to this guy from New
York most likely the LIE is
contentment
most likely he's not as happy as he
wants to be most likely he has unreached
potential that's a serious issue for a
lot of people and the older you get the
stronger that grows
right when you look at yourself in the
mirror and you you know time has passed
that you wasted that starts to eat at
you that can start to eat at you and so
here's what I told this guy said listen
discipline that you're looking for that
motivation that discipline you're
looking for discipline is rooted in the
truth we tell ourselves
discipline is rooted in the truth that
we tell ourselves and this is g i a
couple weeks later I was doing a gig
with JP JP DaNell and I told you know we
were having a discussion about where he
was at and I told him the same thing
discipline is rooted in the truth we
tell ourselves
if you tell yourself the truth
you'll find discipline
and actually if you tell yourself the
truth most likely discipline will find
you
so do not lie to yourself
do not lie to yourself and believe it or
not we tend to do that
we tend to just say I am actually pretty
happy
I'm actually pretty happy
we tend to tell ourselves
a lie
either that and your lie could be I want
more and I want to do more that could be
a lie you could be content with where
you're at or your lie is that I'm happy
and by the way if you want more go
freaking get it and if you're happy cool
enjoy it if you get if you pull that
truth out of yourself and you know what
I'm freaking stoked I gotta I got a
house I got a girlfriend I got Netflix
I'm good if that's where you get cool
enjoy it
but don't lie to yourself and here's
what you got to watch out for
people lie
about the hard games
people lie about the hard games people
lie about you know oh I don't really
care about money
it's freaking hard to make money
and so people lie about it yeah
or you know I don't really I don't want
to I don't want to spend my whole life
working I don't care how big I don't
care how strong I am it's a lie yeah
not in all cases but in a lot of cases
um I don't really care about having oh I
don't want some big house then you just
got to take care of it okay
that could be a lie put your lie
detector on if the goal that you're
talking about you don't care about is
big and takes hard work put your lie
detector on it and make sure you're not
lying to yourself
if you don't care if you truly don't
care that's cool that's fine
but if you do care
don't lie to yourself
now you might have to put some realistic
goals on yourself
right you might have to be like okay I'm
not happy with where I'm at this is what
I want you know I want a freaking
mansion
or I want I wanna I wanna a house on
beachfront Malibu
20 mil by the way that might not be a
realistic goal for you but if you're
like well you know I I don't really care
about that so I'm good with my apartment
over here good renting my apartment over
here
if that's really if you really like look
at your life and you look at your game
and you look at your plan and you look
at your where you're going to be and
you're like I like renting an apartment
and this is where I'm truly happy okay
but I'm asking you please don't lie to
yourself
this happens with uh with people going
through SEAL training they say they want
to be a seal
big they sign up for six years of their
lives
they tell all their friends that they're
going to be a seal they tell their
girlfriend they're going to be a seal
they tell their parents and their
grandparents they're going to be a seal
and then it gets cold
and they decide I don't really care
about being a seal it's not really
not really for me
it's not true
that's a lie and they quit and then two
days later or two hours later they're
like damn I know I actually do I do want
to do that yeah but at the moment of
truth you lied to yourself
so that's what we end up doing a lot
we end up doing a lot of lying to
ourselves
about the game that we're playing about
the game that we want to play about the
game that we should play
and we don't tell ourselves the truth
about it
this is also why it's very important to
be able to take a step back and detach
because your little conniving mind
will outsmart you
it will outsmart you
and it'll agree with the fact that you
really don't care about
you know having a good relationship with
this girl or this guy
or it'll say you know what I don't
really care about getting Advanced at
work because I I'm good with where I'm
at
your mind will tell you that and and
you've got to watch out because your
mind is smart it knows how to manipulate
you
knows what to say
so
pay attention to the game that you're
playing
select the right game
and make sure
that you don't lie to yourself
so the the lying to yourself like
that goes super deep
like lying to yourself about like did I
hit a nerve over there
yeah you did actually kind of but you
know and you make this joke sometimes
where you'll we're talking about 20 reps
squat right and you're like I don't know
if it's even I don't even know if I care
about being strong no no you're giving
me like you're giving me a little bit
too much like niceness I'm really like
doing a 20 rep spot like I don't even
care about me this is stupid yeah
that weak part of my brain gets
aggressive oh yeah dude this is you're
gonna get hurt yeah okay
you're gonna get hurt you know you're
gonna get hurt and you're not gonna be
able to roll you're not gonna be able to
Surf like you should just
how big do you want how strong do you
need to be yes bro it's just take it
easy yeah and the thing is that like
that and that's why I was kind of
laughing because I thought about that
and but and I I have some some pretty
bad ones as well where you know you and
the LIE is that like you don't really
care that much about being strong the
thing is like being strong is important
always has been important you just don't
want to [__] suffer right there hey
check this out if if you went into the
gym
and someone's like at that moment and
they're like if they break and they go
you know I don't really care about being
strong and then you're like hey here's a
pill you can take it'll make you
freaking super strong 100 of people are
taking it there's no one that says that
I don't want that pill yeah there's
people that aren't willing to make the
sacrifice yes and because let's face it
dude you do those 20 reps squats bro
brother yeah that's a that's like a site
it can be like a psychedelic experience
like you know when you get to like the I
thought you're gonna say psychotraumatic
experience
yeah well I don't know I guess depends
on who you are it depends how much
weight you're doing depends on how you
feel but yeah psychedelic but what you
just said there was like they don't want
to make the sacrifice right and that
sacrifice looks like a that's a bunch of
different things depending on what
you're doing but really that's the truth
but that's a hard truth to say it's like
it seems way more comforting to be like
that's not really that worth it because
when something's not worth it and it's
like clear it's like yeah yeah like it's
like yeah I could go to the store but
it's not worth it for whatever I'm
trying to get or whatever like that's
easy that's an easy one to accept
but if you're like yeah it is worth it
and but right now I don't want to endure
that suffering I'm too like mentally
weak or whatever you want to you know
whatever this situation is like I'm too
mentally weak to go through that stuff
right now for this 25 seconds well
that's hard what's funny is you never
say I'm too mentally weak to go through
this because if you say that you don't
you actually you actually wreck what
you'll say is like I don't you know I
don't think I should get injured I don't
think I should push myself you got all
these other excuses that you'll make and
what's what what we have to watch out
for
is we can Propel ourselves down the path
in life of getting on the easiest game
exactly right you can say hey here's the
easiest path to take that's a good
enough game for me and listen this is
what you got to watch out for you got to
watch out for on
utilized potential that you have as a
human being
if you have unutilized potential as a
that's what ends up in my opinion
becoming regret yeah I see that that
becomes resentment towards other people
as well you ever you know we talked
about this on the last podcast of like
oh your friends don't want you to
succeed there's some friends that don't
want you to succeed yeah that's because
they know that they didn't do what they
were supposed to do you ever see someone
like doing something that's hardcore and
you're like a little bit jealous and mad
and like frustrated
uh I I feel like I probably have yes but
I can't think of anything off him but I
understand what you're saying yes when
I'm when you see like oh uh Jocko like I
posted oh I just got done training Jiu
Jitsu and you didn't are you a little
bit mad
yeah a little bit right sometimes a
little bit mad because because it's a
reflection of you yes you decided not to
train yeah that was your choice yeah
shit's getting personal you know what's
real funny about that is like that
you're right in
you're writing probably more ways than
you think because sometimes I'll be like
I'll be like uh he didn't call me to go
train you know sometimes you'll like
text and be like training news time or
whatever and then like then I'll see
whatever someone posts a picture of
themselves with you training and I'm
like oh it's like it's almost like a
justification you know I'm like oh you
didn't call me but yeah whatever you
know kind of thing but really the the
real pain is like that I just didn't go
straight yeah you know that you did and
I didn't so imagine that over a lifetime
like we're talking about one training
session makes you feel a little bit but
but imagine you look up and you know
that someone else who's pretty much the
same level human as you like look I look
at some people like damn that person's
doing I don't have the capability of
doing what they're doing in that Arena
yeah like whatever that arena is yeah
freaking Tom Brady right what's this
dude doing like there's this is a human
that was built for that game uh
uh Gordon Ryan right this is a human
that's built for that game
and both those guys massive work ethic
dedication
just that's what they're good that's
what that's the game that they're
playing and they've committed that game
and they're born for that game so
I'm over here I'm not looking at Gordon
Ryan like
uh frustrated about him I might be like
damn bro I might be like that that dude
is
I actually it's just actually I know I'm
trying to think of what my emotions are
when I look at Tom Brady or I look at
Michael Jordan or I look at Gordon Ryan
it's like oh that's a human that got the
blessing of having a a level of natural
ability that then took it to the nth
degree good for them bro yeah respect
yes I don't even feel frustrated about
that here's where people get frustrated
they look at Joe schmoe
and they go dude Joe schmoe did this and
I'm sitting over here and that person
did better than me I didn't know I have
more Talent than them yeah that's where
people get pissed that's where people
get resentful yeah that's what it feels
like where like Yeah you mentioned these
like Elite level you know Gordon Ryan
and Michael Jordan top right Tom Brady
it's almost like they're so good and so
like we're they they have they connected
all their dots in their whole life
potential uh gifts and work ethic and
like you don't even compare yourself
with them because of all these elements
that are different so like you know when
someone's like in the same Lane as you
that's when you're gonna be paying
attention you know where certain people
even if someone's like just playing a
whole different game like someone who's
like won the Nobel Prize there are other
people in there in their little
environment yeah their ecosystem they're
like yeah I should have won the Nobel
Prize or they'll be haterish or whatever
but you if you're not pursuing the Nobel
Prize you're kind of like oh that's
pretty impressive you know you don't
care at all you're just not in that lane
what's the deal with Tom Brady as far as
like you know you see these the the
numbers that he did in the combine when
he was getting uh drafted and he was
like not you know horrible numbers I
think like the worst 40 and they show
pictures of him he had no vertical so
was he just not like the best athlete
and then he got he worked to get that
athletic or was he just not been on the
right program wait is Tom Brady Super
athletic now or something I mean he's
freaking one however many Super Bowls
yeah so awesome shape at 45 years old
yeah yeah fully so yeah there's an you
know this like where there's different
like types of athlete but more than that
it's more what kind of player are you
like how good of a player are you so
certain positions if you're more
athletic that's going to add to how good
of a player you got to have other
elements for sure oh yeah 100 now
quarterback is kind of the most cerebral
one of the thing so he's he got to be he
has to be a good football player like
quarterback so there's something in his
mind and you can train all all this
stuff like in and of course physically
like he's a tall guy you know that helps
and you got physical attributes for sure
but just because you don't have a
vertical like that's more like
basketball your vertical it's gonna
matter more than the mean of course do
you think he do you think he was not on
the right program and then once he
started getting honed he was able to
become more because let's face it like
he could have been a a really good
athlete that just didn't know how to
train right yeah is that possible yeah
yeah very positive I didn't do some
research yeah but you tend to get like
these really good and I told you about
my friend Tim Carey where he um he was a
quarterback at uh I actually talked to
him briefly he was uh he I think he
played in Canada for a little bit too
but and I'm not saying he's not a Tom
Brady level athlete but he was so good
he but he was one of those guys where
you tell him around a 40 he's not very
fast he was pretty tall but you tell him
to jump a vertical he's not going to be
one of the highest vertical guys you
know but his mind and his just way of
connecting with the people around him on
the team or whatever was like you could
tell you he was really good at that and
I'm sure you can train that a lot of his
like personality but it's like the way
you're in touch with the game and with
your game that's gonna really tell the
tale more so than how fast you run the
40 or do those combine exercises Fedor
yeah so one thing about Fedor when
people talk about the different talents
that people have right
and you got
you know some fighter is super explosive
right yeah you got uh Joel Romero right
just explosive he's like a superhero
explosive you got some other guy that
could you know Nate Diaz just go
endurance bro he's just gonna he's gonna
keep going nothing gonna stop him yeah
from an endurance perspective BJ Penn
flexible super flexible you got guys
that just cardio machines Frankie Edgar
right so there's different people have
different talents what I always found
about Fedor malianenko who a lot of
people say is the best heavyweight of
all time uh in mixed martial arts what I
I thought like his talents
was that he knew how to fight really
good you know like he knew how to take
his wrestling his boxing his striking
his grappling he knew how to take all
those things his talent was being able
to put them all into one into one
package and utilize the right skill at
the right time yeah better than anyone
else in his era yeah and you know here's
another one too and you mentioned this
every once in a while where he was
unshakable like he wasn't the kind where
like you get him in trouble and it that
means something to that you're gonna be
trouble means nothing to me there's
nothing to him yeah because look at
Kevin Randleman just picking him in
smashing him on his spine yeah like
where you look at her Airborne airborne
and you think there you think at least
there's a decent chance this guy's is
going to be paralyzed you know literally
paralyzed from the neck down because he
gets smashed on his head and he hits the
ground he looks like it looks like I
just walked up to you and like said hi
that's the expression he just looks
totally normal and he gets a guy in the
camera yeah but that you see that and
you go okay that's what that guy's
Talent was was taking all those things
like he if there was no MMA and there
was just boxing he wouldn't have been a
world champion boxer if there was this
wrestling he wouldn't have been a world
champion wrestler because there was
people that would beat him and wrestling
there's people that beat him in boxing
there's people that beat him in [__]
but you take all those things and put
them together and he that's what the
skill he had yeah so when we're cruising
around life
you if you can and you can identify what
talent you have
that can help you identify what game you
should get into
and if you're lucky
the game that you're good at is the game
that you also like to play right because
there's some people that have a natural
skill but they don't like that that game
right there's also some people that lack
a skill but they love that game
look I I'm I'm okay with that to an
extent right like hey I really love this
game I suck at it but I'm gonna go for
it
I appreciate the heart man and you you
that might be the right move for you
because then you're doing something that
you love and you get beat it doesn't
really matter as long as you accept that
and you understand that and you
understand what winning is going to look
like for you in that particular game but
if you're not paying attention to that
you might be getting involved you might
be it's the same thing you hear with uh
you know oh I just always did what my
parents wanted me to do and that's why I
went to law school and now I'm a lawyer
and I hate it yeah right like watch out
for that if you don't like if that's not
the game you want to play at all
and your parents are getting your law
school and you want to be a welder
because you like fabricating stuff with
your hands let me tell you what game you
should pick you should pick that
fabrication you should become a welder
because your passion and your love for
well-being will more than make up for
the fact that it might start off with a
lower income than being a lawyer which
by the way probably isn't even true
these days because being a lawyer
there's so many lawyers out there it
takes a long time to build up your life
your book business and it depends on
what kind of lawyer you are like I know
a handful of lawyers and most of them
are don't make that much money that's
very true very true and most welders
they make pretty good money
so that's what game you want to get in
yeah and you and you and you just you
just have to pay attention yourself
and what I would say about both those
your parents want you to be a lawyer
they've told you to be a lawyer
if you lie to yourself
it ain't gonna work out well bro you
made a really good point with the
Admirals and stuff where and then UFC
has that where you know you put all your
eggs in that basket playing that game
hardcore and then once it's over you're
sort of done so
um I know like
you know professional sports that can be
the case and you know you ever watch the
what's the show The Rock used to be in
and he was like a sports financial
advisor no idea it was it was a show I
used to watch it for a while and I was
like I don't get what this guy is that
when I first started watching it and I
was like oh what he does is he manages
like the money and the financial future
of athletes that come in because you
know you come out of high school yeah he
squeaked out a degree a little bit you
went to the draft or whatever and your
whole your whole plan for your whole
life all your eggs in the Ambassador
football and then nothing else
afterwards right and you're playing
football that's all you're doing
football party whatever whatever so The
Rock was like an advisor that he would
help plan like hey you should you should
take some of your money invest it here
so when you're done playing football
because when you play football you don't
think about after football you're
singing forget football forever well
unfortunately most people between most
men for sure between the ages of 15 and
30 aren't thinking about anything you
all think you're gonna not you're not
worried about hey someone will happen
yeah which is by the way lying to
yourself yes so true
so he was he would do that and that like
kind of man you can obviously we don't
have a lot of us don't have financial
advisors when we get our first great job
you know but it's like that's the kind
of mindset you kind of got to keep
that's going to help you you know like
that hey this is going to end this job
is going to end and then what am I going
to do so some jobs are good where you
can have that job and you get so much
experience just by doing the job that
like when you're done you're like oh
shoot to me Admiral seems like one of
those jobs I don't know yeah no there's
definitely like I said the military
industrial complex is looking to hire
you up and making a freaking whatever
their thing in their board meeting and
you're gonna go to the big meeting and
get more missiles bought by the Navy or
whatever that's going on for sure but
UFC fighter not guaranteed by the way
what I just said
there's always a slot there's always
some slots for that flag officer but
also that flag officer is like well
they're like yeah yeah we got a job for
you just got to move to whatever this
place is and the guy's like well I
wanted to retire to Tennessee I'm like
well we don't need someone in Tennessee
we need someone in Washington DC
Tennessee or DC you we need you in DC
not Tennessee and so then they're like
oh I guess I'll just not do that and
look you're got an Admirals you got an
admiral's pay Admiral's retirement or a
general's retirement which is good money
but it's not getting you anything close
to the life that you had when you were
an active duty General officer because
you had a driver and you had a car and
you had a freaking airplane yeah you
weren't flying around in Delta you're
not flying around in America you had a
plane and you're hey bro I'm going there
now I'm going there now there's a big
group of people waiting for you and
they're feeding you extravagant foods
and treating you with respect all of a
sudden next thing you know you're on
Delta Airlines in the cheap seats you
know so that's where it sneaks up on
people yeah and there's people that do
that in every industry that happens in
in the in the academics it happens in
the financial industry it happens in any
industry yeah any any job that you can
have if you don't recognize the
ecosystem that that job actually
encompasses and think that it
encompasses more if you think that the
ecosystem encompasses the whole world
yeah like there's
like being a seal right no one like
there's an admiral seal there's me
there's some other guy that did four
years it's Australian world that's just
a seal they're all the same dude right
well this guy was an admiral sure some
people might say well Admiral sounds
pretty important well this guy over here
says yeah I was a master chief goes a
little Master Chief Admiral those guys
both sound pretty awesome to me right
this is it's like the same thing
so you think that that ecosystem expands
to Encompass the whole universe and you
think it expands to Encompass life it
doesn't yeah
so if you're not paying attention you
will be invested in a game where when
you walk off the court no one cares what
the score was yeah people do that with
Academia like you're going to college
and they're trying to get good grades
and all this stuff no one cares no one
wants to see your report card actually a
lot of times they don't even care what
university you went to sure if you went
to the big whatever big ivy league
there's people that care about that but
then there's also be like I don't care
where you went to school whatever you
went to Harvard you went to Princeton
you went to Berkeley you went to Yale
you went to wherever to say okay cool
whatever we don't care can you perform
in this job
and that's the question
so if we're not thinking about that we
end up with issues that's why you know
I've told vets for all these years
you need to find a new Mission find a
new Mission because that once you're out
of the military no one calls you master
chief anymore no one calls you Commander
anymore it doesn't happen she sure you
can go to the country club and someone
calls you Admiral if you tell them all
about it but they they're just kind of
like whatever it's no big deal
so we have to be careful about this you
know the the UFC thing for sure is the
you know guys that fought in the UFC and
then that's over you know even Jiu Jitsu
guys like oh that's over like you just
said football guys like you're on you're
on an NFL football team nowadays cool
you're gonna get a good retirement
you're gonna be taken care of but back
in the day back in the 70s like you got
done no no no you don't have any money
yeah no one cares you gotta go get a job
yeah you gotta go get an actual job
that's weird that's a strange thing yeah
actually yeah my uncle he died but he uh
he played in the NFL for like six years
or whatever what team
um I know he played for Cleveland and
he's old school he's like he would have
been like 80 oh damn he was old he was
Hardcore leather helmet no not quite but
nonetheless when I first I heard about
him whenever when I first met him when
he came to visit or whatever he was like
yeah he was like just a normal dude I
thought you know he's huge but he was
like um I thought it was gonna be some
big time Rich dude because he got that
NFL money you know but no like when
you're done you sort of got I mean
unless you're focusing right when you
get that you focus on retirement and
investing all that stuff most people
don't do that so you just came as just a
normal dude
I think he worked in like I don't know
some actually I think he owned like a
shop or something I don't know yeah but
what's interesting is if you were in the
NFL back then
or you're in the UFC five years ago 10
years ago and you recognized the
limitations of the game you were
investing in and you pulled chips off
the table in that game and put it into
the bigger game yeah that's how you win
that's how you look up and go yeah you
know I didn't you know I didn't do great
in the UFC I fought for the belt twice
didn't win it but I you know bought
these three apartment buildings yeah you
know over a five-year period yeah two of
them are paid for you know what I mean
and then all of a sudden you go oh
so the only way you get to see that is
by following the advice we gave on the
last podcast take a step back and write
down the game that you're in and the
multiple games that you're in and then
what are the strategies to win these
games yeah and by the way you can be
playing a game a short-term game a
subordinate game
that is going to cost you in the
Strategic victory of the Supreme game
yeah
so you're doing dumb things hey oh I'm
gonna deal some drugs right now right I
want to deal some drugs and make some
money right now then you get caught and
now you're screwed yeah so you can do
you can make mistakes
in the short term games you can get
involved in games that don't matter you
get involved in games that take away
your resources and if you do that you're
gonna you're gonna sacrifice the Supreme
game again please go and write down
take a step back detach and write down
the various games and subordinate games
that you're involved in well look we're
all playing at least one big game
together yeah all of us yeah and you
know for you
winning the game of life might be hey
I've got a big family I've got a bunch
of kids I've got a bunch of grandkids
that's a w you might be hey I'm not
really into a big family but I got a
bunch of properties and I gotta
um I know I can spend my final years
doing whatever I want that's your W if
that's your W fine maybe it's a look I
don't really care about money but I want
to live by the beach or I want to live
in the mountains and I want to be left
alone and not have to worry about
anything and that's the W okay
cool figure out what that win looks like
figure out what that W is and then
figure out how you're going to play that
game to win
do you you know you heard the the whole
thing where
um you know people do this where they'll
interview people who are like really old
and sometimes they interview like the
super successful people who are really
old and kind of retired or whatever and
they say like what are your regrets or
whatever
oh and it's usually stuff that they
didn't do or maybe I should have put
okay so I have two questions hey do you
ever uh like do that is that ever like a
motive not a motivator but like a um
like a tool you use to be like hey I I
should do more or whatever by thinking
like oh I don't want to be old and
regret not doing certain things yeah I
think that I think when I talked earlier
about the knowing that you have a
certain level of potential yeah knowing
that
you have a certain amount of time
knowing that I have opportunities that
some of my friends don't have anymore
yeah it's like oh if you don't think I'm
gonna try and do my best to
fulfill the potential that I have to to
squeeze what I can out of life
well yeah no of course I think that way
you know I think about all my friends
that don't have that opportunity yeah so
do you think of now do you ever think of
like things in the past like that you
kind of can't do anymore because you're
not in that position anymore you know
like sometimes when you're like hey I
should
enjoyed myself more in my 20s or
whatever do you ever think that I
enjoyed myself a lot seriously you don't
have any other direction I'm like I
enjoy myself a little bit too much in my
20s yeah you know what I'm saying yeah I
was I was playing that game pretty hard
yeah right and I played it a little too
hard you know I probably should have a
little bit a little bit smarter but I
think also
you know I I think that the years that I
was like you know blowing money on
partying and chicks and just all that
crap I think in those years I also
those were years that were a little bit
for lack of a better word a little bit
Expendable meaning like
that's what I was doing I knew I had a
longer future you know and knew I'd be
able to kind of have some time to put
that together but that being said I've
told my kids I've been like oh if I
would have been smarter the the whole
the whole world would be different you
know so I guess I do have
when I if I think about it kind of
bifurcate the two thoughts one of them
is like well yeah I had a good time and
it was fun but also if I look at it from
a more mature aspect it's like yeah you
know I would have been in a much better
position
now then then I am now listen I will say
that I'm in a really good position right
now in my life like I mean I've got good
stuff going on
I kind of have what I what I want yeah
um
but you know if I wouldn't have
gotten onto this path that we're on
right now
you know if I if I would have retired
from the military and run the gym and
taught jiu jitsu
and I had to look around right now and
look at the time and money that I wasted
as a 20 to as an 18 19 20 21 22 23 24
year old I'd be like damn I should I
wasted I blew a lot of stuff luckily
like I said I think of made maneuvers
once I identified the game that I was
playing which I didn't really do until I
was like 25 years old it's like okay I
see this game okay now I'm in a game
here's the here's the menu here's the
moves that I have to make here's the
things that I have to do to set myself
up for the long run and once I did that
then I was able to sort it out but if I
and then and then continued to identify
oh this is the game that's going on
right now okay here's here's how I can
make moves so I think if I wouldn't have
identified that
I would be totally regretful yeah but as
of right now you're you're kind of song
No I feel good and then the other
question I got to ask yourself well if I
didn't have those other experiences
would I be who I am right now and the
answer is probably no probably not yeah
you know so I I was
doing things and learning about life and
going through experiences that I learned
a lot from
and I think that was beneficial yeah and
it makes me who I am
so yeah I feel like you're you know in
your position and a lot of people in the
position where you have you had such a
like action packed for like a better
term
yeah like young life you know that it's
hard to be like man I wish it because
you know you you bring up um yeah people
who follow their parents dreams you know
and then they get and even when they're
for real successful they'll be like dang
I wish I would have yeah I wish I would
have paid attention more to my friends
or my whatever my family or whatever or
even if they just say I wish I would
have followed my dreams instead of my
parents Dreams yeah yeah so this is to
your case in point I followed my dreams
from day one like from day one I was
like Hey I want to go be a frog man I'm
gonna go get after it like that's what
I'm doing and I did it and so that's to
me
uh very
very
satisfying gratifying and re regret
removal right yeah fully like I think if
I if I had not done what I had wanted to
do like well you know you played
football is there a part of you that
goes man if I would have pushed a little
bit harder if I would have trained a
little bit harder if I would have been a
little bit more dedicated I probably
could have you know maybe I could have
gone whatever maybe I could have gone to
the NFL maybe I could have done or you
didn't have those thoughts no you're
sure yeah not even close so I I think I
think you didn't have the capability of
going to the NFL
um I don't I don't know I mean put it
this way the guys that on my team that I
know that went to the NFL were like way
more gifted than me so way more gifted
or away all across the board or did they
work harder though yeah yeah both and
here's what I realized like within two
years it was actually after I got
injured I had to work my way back into
the depth chart is like I don't like
football enough to like have to play
this game as hard as everyone I'm
looking around and guys are like they're
down for the grind the football and
that's football and they're watching the
games on the weekends and all this one
remember I don't care I kind of
to be honest I kind of care more about
the party on after the game than you
know like practice and like all this
stuff I liked lifting weights I like
that part of it and certain like running
drills I like that part of it but
I think the the reality of what it takes
to play football like wasn't worth it at
all
to me after like about two years yeah in
college in high school it's like you're
just into working out and you run faster
than everybody so it's you can catch
good so you make touchdowns if you're
good at football in in high school like
you're just gonna live a good life you
know kind of a thing and then so it
wasn't it didn't take the kind of work
it did in college so it really brings to
light like what it takes and you're like
oh bro this isn't even like I don't even
like football that much I like it but
not that much what if you were still a
bouncer right now no so you know would
you kind of be like damn I wish I could
no I would have if this is the if if I
was I'm just trying to see if you lied
to yours did you lie to yourself at all
when you were like you know what I don't
care about that much about football were
you just saying that because it was a
bunch of hard work and you're like oh I
don't really care about football it's
like what I talked about earlier today
yeah
um
no because it doesn't feel like it
anyway because I don't even know I don't
watch football it's not because like I
have sour grades or nothing but I like
I'll try to watch football because I
want my son to kind of be into it and
think I'll cut and it is fun to watch
but I'm like not into it really I'm not
into it so there's truly
zero regret for your football career you
know what I think I think what drew me
to football was my dad's like he was so
proud that because Jay Jordan football
first one year like when he was 10 when
we were 10. and my dad was so proud of
him and I'd watch him play and how
everyone just loved it and all this
stuff so I was like oh okay and then the
next year I went and we were good you
know coming up or whatever so it's like
you just get the payoff of being good
more so than it really liked football I
think I did it for my dad to be honest
like no so you truly have no regret
the football thing no
um that's good yeah that's good because
there's some people that you know would
have been uh invested and and from what
you're saying you weren't actually that
had you know uh let's say a 80 natural
Talent if 100 gets you to the NFL you're
at 80 yeah you could have made it up to
87 because you would if you would have
worked really super hard but you still
wouldn't have been there yeah so
consider who went to the NFL from my
team that I mean there's some other guys
kind of later on but Ashley Lilly 6'3
around a four two something 40. he went
to the NFL uh my friend Jeff ulbrich
when he ran a four five he weighs 255
he's 61.
good at football that's the thing too
okay and Ashley has all these touchdowns
and like just good at football
um my friend Adrian clamp who went he
was a lineman he was six five three
hundred pounds and good at football long
arms he was alive really these are real
these are Elite athletes yeah dude in
division one college football so you
don't just go to that NFL
um you had that realization was there
anybody that surprised you
anybody that like you know little Freddy
oh yeah yeah they're they're the handful
of those guys
um they usually make it to like the
combine stuff and the practice squad and
they do some work there but they don't
they don't go and play in the NFL you
know um no surprises yeah there was um I
totally forget his name oh man everybody
went into the local guy went to the NFL
played on some some squads didn't play
in games or nothing but played on some
square there's a few guys yeah if you're
just playing Squad are you getting paid
yeah yeah good morning practice better
than like a normal job for sure yeah
better than your average job oh yeah
like you can get and that could that
benefit of you and could that affect you
yeah like if if I would if I was gung-ho
about football like these yeah yeah I
think so all right because I I you
assessed that the game was not for you
the game was not for me
the game I chose one I didn't ever I
didn't have a contingency again I just
like I was I didn't have really like
like goals I was just trying to do
whatever won't be a personal trainer or
something like this and then you know
work in the clubs you know when you're
20. it's like whatever 21 22 years old
no it was it was well into the club
where I was like hey I got to do
something like creative you know with
with people that I like that are like
that has a real future not just the
manager of a nightclub you know like
that's not a I didn't see that as who I
was kind of a thing
so I yeah I joined with my brother and
we started stuff
well
I'm glad you were able to assess
actually you taught me something
passively what's that
you know how you're like a Navy SEAL or
were whatever whatever
um but then you're also a black belt in
Jiu Jitsu and this is what I found out
about you or like early on too where you
like dabbled in like real estate
and then I didn't find out you were this
leadership dude or had that until Tim
Ferriss podcast I literally didn't even
know that dang
um so the point there is you have like
five that's like what four or five
different viable games to play five yeah
like very viable just alone but you have
five of them going on at the same time
yes and that is something that is a
strategy
and of and it the weird thing is and I'd
say that this is probably you know we
talked about Fedor Talent being able to
put it all together I would say the
little bit of talent that I have because
you know me I'm not that talented in
anything really but what I was pretty
talented at was being able to like work
hard in a bunch of different things yeah
kind of simultaneously yeah like kind of
like I'm gonna do these things and they
all are time suckers and they all take a
lot of effort and time but I'm gonna go
ahead and do them all at the same time
yeah and I think that's it's hard to do
that
uh and in some in a lot of cases it's
not even smart to do that because in a
lot of cases
you know if you're doing one thing and
then you're doing something else and
you're doing something else and you're
doing something else you're not
prioritizing and executing you're not
focusing your resources properly to
actually make anything happen
so that
in many cases is negative to to try and
do a bunch of things at the same time
you know I I would say like
how much more dedicated I was I was very
dedicated to jiu jitsu and I still
train all the time but
and there was a time maybe where I was
pretty good but like training when I'm
training with Dean Lester and I'm
training with Dean and he's like a world
champion
I recognize kind of like what you're
saying there was a gap
in natural ability that would not be uh
would not be closed by any amount of
work yeah you know there's a there's a
certain level that he is and then I'd
train with other world champions I'd be
like okay yep that person's better than
me now Look I could have gotten close
that Gap more yeah you know if I'd have
been like all right you know what I'm
just getting out of the Navy
and I'm gonna just do Jiu Jitsu all the
time sure I could close that Gap more
for sure 100 obviously
um but yeah I think that's that's me
working hard and not only that
uh when it does come to prioritize and
execute
when I'm when I was doing one thing like
I would do that thing yeah and then two
hours later I'm doing something else I'm
focused on that thing and then two hours
later I'm doing the other thing I'm
doing it so I think the amount of focus
that I would bring to the table when it
came to pursuing goals was strong and
I never like I never sacrificed a one
second of work
in the SEAL Teams for anything else for
nothing else like there was no way that
I was gonna ever be like oh I gotta go
be I know I never left work never never
never was like nope I gotta go that's
why you know for many many years Dean
and I trained it eight o'clock at night
because that's when I could safely know
you know you get to work at six o'clock
in the morning I know by eight o'clock I
can get to the mats because I was never
gonna
prioritize anything above the primary
job which is being in a leadership role
in the SEAL Teams which is going to
Trump all other things
so you um
some of it though in maybe you're like
yeah some of your stuff where you know
especially now it's clear but maybe
maybe early on it wasn't but you know
like a lot of your stuff all the things
that you're good at like certifiably
good at
you produce results in they like kind of
can play off each other true you know so
like it's not like you're like hey I'm
gonna pursue being a rock star and then
run Echelon front it's like they're two
they're so different I mean unless
you're playing songs for them at the on
the weekends or whatever but you they
don't like
yes sir they don't play off each other
as much you know right but the the Venn
diagram overlap yeah of Jiu Jitsu of
SEAL Teams of leadership and you know
like you know then you got like the real
estate thing and that was always just a
matter of me was like there's a game
going on here yeah and as soon as I
realized that oh
hey man like I realized when I was
pretty young I'm paying someone else's
mortgage yeah when I'm paying rent I'm
paying someone else's mortgage how do
you win that game the answer is you do
not win that game you do not win that
game you do not win that game you have
to get in a position where you're
putting money and Equity into your
future not someone else's future so
that's the kind of thing where I was
like yes that's a move I'm gonna make
and I'm gonna sacrifice to be able to do
it I was house poor my entire Navy
career completely houseport driving a
1997 Dodge Grand Caravan for 13 years
that's a piece of [__] car man that's
like there's no that's that's an ego uh
you know you see guys with their big
trucks in the other end of the spectrum
later this is the deflator like hey I'm
rolling up in a 1997 the freaking window
on the driver's side didn't work it says
taped up yeah but uh that's what's
that's when I re when I realized that
these games were in play that's when I
started to be able to play the game
whether that game is like oh
real estate paying someone else's paying
rent is paying out someone else's
mortgage that's not a winning game
that's not how you win that game am I
always going to need a house kind of I'm
always going to need a place to live I
got a family and believe me there was
times where I looked at oh I can live in
uh you know I was gonna do the boat
liver board thing a lot of people a lot
of Team guys do that like I'll just live
aboard a boat whatever save that money
cool but again
you all you have to do is study that for
15 minutes and you realize that a boat
is a depreciating asset it doesn't get
it loses value over time all of them
like okay you can get a car that's a
that's a classic or whatever that's very
rare
cars boats planes they're all
depreciating assets so when I realized
that it's like okay well I'll move on a
boat okay that's a depreciating asset
and over time I'm gonna end up in a
worse spot the only way to do this is I
gotta buy a house okay then once I
bought a house it was like okay well how
long do I need to hold on to this house
before I can buy another one how long
for another one how long for another one
and
when again when you look at all these
different things that are happening you
can start to say oh I can at least see
the game that's being played and I can
get in the game yeah
that's my recommendation
ah with that we will continue this
thread
we'll see
um oh perhaps on the next podcast I
don't know we'll review this one and see
if there's a little bit more to add to
it if anyone has questions about this
one hit us up yeah this one's helpful
man for even for me just listening it's
like man that's so helpful well that's
what I realized with these past couple
podcasts if I've got friends that I
communicate with regularly and they
don't realize this stuff I know there's
a lot of people that I haven't done a
good job of communicating this to I know
that
you know look I cover a lot of military
stuff cover a lot of leadership stuff
but it's interesting when I talk about
military and Leadership things I always
think that
the correlations to life are so obvious
but they're not as obvious as you think
they are it's not as obvious as I think
they are so this is one of those where
hopefully people can see through pretty
direct communication the the concepts
that we're talking about and everyone is
susceptible to the problems
that can occur if you don't know
about the game
huh
So speaking of that um we got chocolate
fuel we we both um have been drinking a
lot you drink a Mulk during this yes how
was it good not signing banana cream all
day okay not as obvious as my normal
chocolate but bro I I seriously drink
two of those a day yeah because I got
that freaking stockpile at home yeah so
get yourself some protein it's really
easy you know you first alerted me to
the fact that if you're trying to get
the amount of protein that you need
30 grams of protein is a is a legitimate
nudge yep it's a legitimate like oh this
is a this is a legitimate boost yeah to
the protein intake I think that's more
than a normal like what do you call like
your FD on like a normal meal like a
normal one serving meal or whatever 30
grams is more than in a normal meal
there you go so Mulk we got these
beautiful drinks
we didn't call them energy drinks I mean
they are called Energy Drinks
technically speaking but they're not
because energy drinks are bad for you
and this one's good for you so we're in
a totally different level it's true
we're not in the game that they're in no
they're the game of poisoning you yeah
we're in the game of making you better
yeah smarter faster stronger
jockofuel.com get some of that you can
get it at Wawa you can get a vitamin
shop the military commissary look if
you're I got word the other day
that there was a military commissary
that was lacking
so hey also check in the uh
in like the health and wellness section
of stores sometimes you're looking in
the energy drink section some stores put
them in there sometimes they put them
over in the in the health and wellness
so check that out Military Commerce
series Hannaford Dash stores in Maryland
wake Fern and ShopRite Circle K in
Florida HEB
shout out to all my people in Texas that
are rolling into HEB and clearing
shelves freaking outstanding thank you
Murphy's Meyer
up in the midwest so there you go Jocko
fuel
get some get some
here's what we like to say around here
yeah let's do also origin USA American
made apparel we're gonna start with Jiu
Jitsu stuff geese when you're doing Jiu
Jitsu you need a good ghee so when I get
the best game and plenty of options so I
don't even worry about like oh I got to
get the one no you can get whichever one
you want why would you run out and buy a
Model T Ford that was Rusty when you
could go out and legitimately buy a
Cadillac
that's because that's the difference
between a normal ghee and An Origin geek
it's it's like that and that's not even
to mention where it's made it's insane
yeah which is a whole nother thing huge
actually probably even Huger when you
really think about the big game yeah if
you will see what I'm saying but yes
Best of Both Worlds uh geez rash guards
got some shirts some hoodies okay so I
have four well actually I have like
eight origin hoodies
a hundred percent the past month and a
half hundred percent every single day
even weekends I wear the hoodies yeah
it's a little chilly out here in
California for The Californians
especially for the Hawaiians be thinking
well you and I were doing some filming
today hell yeah and I had like I wear my
origin hoodie every day and it's just
covered in food I was like dude I gotta
walk it over I gotta give me a second
you know I got like scraps of steak on
here oh there's meatball on there I just
had to clean that thing off because you
know I guess I'm not one of those people
that's super into like you know uh
whatever fashion hey man you look great
the hunky or two got the jeans
Delta genes Delta 68s come on multiple
uh levels of wash too
that's right we got a Wash House yep
that's a thing George usa.com do you
know the Dynamics between the the what
like do you know under what
circumstances you wear the dark the
medium and the light
under what circumstances yeah like you
know when you wear light jeans that's
like a daytime spring it's more casual
dark jeans more like dressy and then
it's a spectrum right you got to know
that kind of stuff when you're in big H
are going out on dates just saying I'm
here to help you got to know the game
you're playing also
Jocko has a store it's called Jocko
store that's where you can represent
with discipline equals Freedom death
core to the Core
on this path shirtle while we're playing
this I've seen the last shirt Locker
shirt no free dopamine no just throwing
that out there as a flag yeah like hey
I'm here no free dopamine yeah if you're
if you're wearing that shirt
and you're looking at Instagram
and you're uh scrolling yeah and it's
sucky it's giving you free dopamine
dopamine don't be dopamine nope
don't let it happen come on it's true
clear your brain clear your brain uh
shirt Locker shirt Locker new shirt
every month
check that one out it's all in Jocko
store.com
subscribe to the podcast go to Jocko
underground check that out Jocko
underground.com go to YouTube
Jocko podcast on YouTube originusa on
YouTube psychological warfare flip side
canvas Dakota Meyer
I talked to him the other day he's just
getting after it just just getting after
it no matter what Dakota Meyer he's got
his own gym down there in Texas if
you're in Texas if you're in the Austin
area go to check out his gym it's called
own the dash yeah Jim
yeah I saw a guy with one of his shirts
on I was like I'll have to go to my
represent
dig it there you go uh books got a bunch
of books chocolate publishing Holly
McKay's book
get one of those we we did another print
of those so pick one of those up awesome
book
uh and I've written a bunch of books so
final spin novel
there's novel things happening with
final spin there's also some novel
things happening with Warrior kid look
we'll talk about this more in the future
but but let's just say we like that the
way things are going uh written a bunch
of books so check those out we also have
Echelon front we solve problems through
leadership all your problems are
leadership problems and we will get them
soft go nationalfront.com if you need
help there if you want to come to one of
our Live Events we also have the extreme
ownership Academy we just redid this
whole thing revamped it actually it's
not even just a revamp it's like a
totally new totally new what is it
website is that what it's called totally
new website we got free courses on there
to take we got Dave Burke and I did of
course free yeah a free course Jamie
Cochran and I did a course
so take those free courses
um go to extreme ownership.com you can
check out some of the other content that
we have because look
this is what what we're talking about
the all these games that we're talking
about you need to win in these games the
way you win in these games by having the
right skills extreme ownership.com will
give you those skills
and if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families gold star families check
out Markley's mom mama Lee she's got a
charity organization you heard her on
the podcast you heard about her son if
you want to donate you want to get
involved go to America's Mighty Warriors
dot org and also don't forget about
Micah Fink who at present time
is up there in the wilderness somewhere
he's got a a small mountain lion in one
hand and he's got a bow and arrow on the
other hand and he's in the pursuit of a
grizzly bear
he's doing right now so go to Heroes and
courses.org if you want to help him help
our veterans
and also
if you want to connect with us we're on
the interwebs echo Charles is on Twitter
he's back on Twitter
mistakes were made
they've been amended growth is re re
respawning his life on Twitter sure yep
so check him out he's at Echo Charles
he's on the gram
he's on the Facebook yep it's true at
Echo Charles I'm at Jocko listen if
you're going to go on there though just
just be careful because there's free
dopamine on there they might as well be
giving you cocaine or methamphetamines
and it's getting better too by the way
just let me throw that out you mean
they're getting better at manipulating
your brain with the algorithm yes the
algorithm is just honed toned yeah like
if you if you are into Jiu Jitsu yeah
but you're really into Uma platas it's
like showing you more and without us if
you're really into surfing but you're uh
you really like Single Fin 70s guns sure
which I do oh yeah that's guess what
just miraculously pops up so they're
tracking on you yeah that's the
algorithm watch out
and thanks to our members of the Army
Navy Air Force Marines who are playing
the ultimate game around the world
preserving freedom
thank you for your service and thanks
also to our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service and all First Responders
thank you for preserving our way of life
here at home and to everyone else out
there
don't lie to yourself
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko